happy to have shacha lovett giving this
next talk about the sunflower conjecture
shachar is an associate professor in the
computer science department at
ucsd university of california san diego
he obtained his phd at weizmann
institute did a postdoc at the institute
for advanced study
and has been a member of the
ucsd ever since he has worked
on numerous areas and literally
everything and
maybe the the main um you know common
thread is
this notion of structure versus
randomness
um maybe i'll say something uh more
personal so i i
met shakha i think in 2005 for the first
time
maybe he doesn't remember he was
interviewing me for the
unit in the army and i think it was like
the hardest test ever
in my life and i think uh
uh ever since he's been giving me very
challenging questions that were very
very intriguing and very very good so
thankful for him yeah so uh let's let's
hope that he will give another one
today perfect thanks avishai
yeah yeah guys i'm very happy to talk
here to be advised to talk here
um and again this is supposed to be like
you know it's a
and my goal in this talk that everybody
would understand everything so
please stop me and ask if you have any
questions
or comments or you know tangential
discussions everything is fine
please let's try to make this as
interactive as possible
and also they're going to be a natural
place where i'll stop for a break
um before we get to slightly more
technical material
um and also this is sort of like a mesh
of several talks i gave in the past
some on the sunflower conjecture someone
a random restriction are going to come
up so
if some of you have seen some of the
things and then i mean
feel free to leave or not or whatever
you want but it's just
hopefully something new here for
everybody also okay and also i want to
add that this is all
joint work with three people with ryan l
weiss who was a grad student at
princeton
keown wu who at the time was an
undergrad
at specking university is now starting
phd student at berkeley working with
abishai
who just started who was my previous phd
student and is now starting a faculty
position at usc
yeah okay
okay good so here is the main
theme of this talk so i'm going to talk
about this conjecture called the
sunflower conjecture in combinatorics
and in particular how it's connected to
questions and
topics that come up in theory cs
and there are two themes i want to
emphasize in this talk because i think
they are
broader than just this specific work and
i think people could utilize them in
other
in other areas as well one is this
connection that
we've been having for many decades now
between tcs
a theoretical computer science and
mathematics and the other one like
which i was saying this is this notion
of structure versus randomness which is
a very useful paradigm for many problems
including the one i'll talk about today
so you know we have this sort of
mathematics and tcs theoretical computer
science and there's this sort of
nice bridge between them and of one
direction is maybe the more obvious one
where you know we use
methyl synthesis yes you know we want to
solve problems
that arise when you're thinking about
computation
and you need a lot of mathematical tools
to solve them coming from various areas
but i think what is even more
interesting sometimes is going in the
reverse direction
where you can use of computational
thinking
to study problems in mathematics that on
the surface don't seem to do to have
anything to do with computation at all
there are completely few math questions
but somehow heaven's the type of
computational thinking seems to be
really useful
and here i listed some examples there
are many other examples you know
and and sometimes i just want people to
sort of even if you study
pure math questions in combinatorics or
in other areas
sometimes it is useful to at least be
aware
to this type of computational thing that
comes up in tcs
and again this stock will be one such
example okay
the other general paradigm is this
notion of structure versus randomness
where you study some type of
mathematical object maybe it's a graph
or a function or a set system or
whatever you're studying
and there are usually two types of
structure versus random that come up
the first type is what i would call a
dichotomy
where you could show that every object
is either
structured or pseudorandom and again for
nothing of both the method
in the conceptual level so structures
mean having some type of structure
while pseudorandom mean looking like a
random object in a
certain way so that's one type and the
other type is
maybe a more refined one but maybe more
widely applied
is more of a decomposition type where
you say well
my object is not purely structured
though purely it's the random but they
can decompose it into a
two parts one part being structured and
the other part being to the random
that's more common and again what do we
actually mean by structure so the random
really depends on the applications
usually one of them would be natural
and the other one would just be the
complement so maybe you know you say
well maybe there's a very natural
structure that if i have it in my
problem
i could make progress on it and lacking
this structure
i recorded to the random or maybe the
other way around maybe there's this very
natural random looking phenomena that i
can understand
and if i don't have it i would call this
structure so whichever one you're
choosing
naturally the other one would complement
it and then
you know you you're trying to understand
how they look
and again again many many examples in
the literature so here again the listed
something maybe the most famous one here
is the seminary regular dilemma
that he used to prove his theorem and
which says that any graph
can be decomposed into basically a small
structural part
and the remainder means the random so
this would be more than the composition
type
anyway this has been information in so
many works in in in
combinatorics graph theory and also in
cs and other areas
and there are many other examples like
that okay so this is this general notion
of structure versus randomness
now let's start talking about the topic
of this
this talk which is sunflowers so here's
a sunflower
but we will be actually interested in
this type of sunflower
which looks similar but not quite the
same this is the sunflower in
combinatorics
so what is a sunflower so it's in our
sunflower
is r is a parameter it's a collection of
our sets s1 s2 up to sr with a very
specific
intersection pattern so all the pairwise
intersections must be the same
so here you see this this diagram so i
have
three sets and you know the the
intersection pattern the venn diagram is
very very specific
so all elements either belong to all of
the sets
or maybe just one of the sets or maybe
to none but then i don't care about them
so but for example they don't have
elements belonging to two sets but not
to the third set
because this is sunflower this is
sunflower with three petals three sets
in general you can have four five six or
some number so two doesn't make any
sense every two sets
correspond to two sunflowers so the
first interesting case is three
so three petals and
again what these common elements that
belong to all of them we call the kernel
and you know these sets we call the
petals but this
looks like a sunflower but it's like a
flower this is sunflower and
the basic question that we are going to
study is this ramsey type question that
says
if you're given a set system so a
statistic is just a collection of sets a
family of sets
maybe some restrictions on them how
large should the set system be
so that it must contain a sunflower
so can i always say that if i have a
large enough set system
then it necessarily contains a sunflow
with some given number like three four
or five petals
okay so why is this an interesting
question well usually it's interesting
because
if i give you arbitrary set with
arbitrary intersection patterns it's
hard to argue about them
but sunflowers have this very very nice
simple intersection pattern
which in many many applications make
them much easier to argue about
and in fact sunflowers you know i'll
tell you they were introduced in the 60s
and they'll probably know dozens of
applications
if not even more both in math and in
computer science
and again you need to so now there are
two variants of this question you can
think about
one is the original one introduced by
erdogan rado in 1960 where we
bound the size of the system so we have
a family of sets and each set has size
at the most some parameter
so we're going to call w that's one
variant
the other variant introduced by sam
already about 20 years later
when we don't bound the side of the sets
but instead
we bound this out of the universe we
have sets out of n elements
but the sets will have any side that you
want and both types
are interesting and both have many
applications
um and i'll talk about both but mostly i
will talk about the other charado
variant
this talk this is the more general one
the other similarly one is actually
special case of the other one
so what we want to prove that every
large will not fill but the set system i
guess
contains the sound like this picture you
see that it's very large field
and in fact it must have a sunflower
inside it
and so again talking about this early
schrader
setup so i will see what have a set
system
f is curly f and i will assume that all
the sets didn't have size exactly w
now you can also assume the size at most
w it's basically the same thing
it doesn't change anything but just for
simplicity i will assume here in this
store with all the setups has exactly w
and i'm going to think of r which is the
side of the sunflower how many sets
i want to find in the center of some
fixed constant and mostly i'm going to
think about three
in this stock so three is a good number
to keep in mind so i want a sunflower
with three petals
three sets and the question is how many
sets
do i have in my set system so that it
must contain a sunflower either even a
bound
could it be they can find infinite such
systems
all the set of size w but still contain
no sunflower
and the sunflower that additional food
but 60 years ago said that well no there
is a bound
and the bond that they proved is this so
if i want to find an r sunflower
and then all the sets of size w or at
most w
then if you have more than w factorial
times r minus one to the w
then your set system must contain some
log
now a bit about that symmetrics here
well if r is three then this is x two to
the w
this factor by the way when i move my
mouse can you see it
let me just verify that are we shy of
assad
yes good okay um and
here this this is a more dominant term
this is w factorial so this this is we
have the w
um so the question is well
what's the right answer and it turns out
there are examples you can read and show
an example in the next slide where
you can get this to be true without this
w factorial
so there are examples of size
exponentially in w
with no sunflower but the lemma that
they proved
says well you need slightly more you
need double as w
so really the whole question is do you
need this w factorial factor
or not so additional conjecture that you
don't need
they said well for every r that's r is
three
there is some constant such that
if your set system is more than this
constant with a w
so the single exponential in w then it
must contain a sunflower
and we know it has to be exponential w
but the body pool is
slightly worse dalton's w and the
question is which one is the right
answer
see the question in the chat we
encourage you
okay yes
perfect yeah turn the video on it will
be nice then we get to see all of you
perfect okay so now the whole question
is which one is the right answer
so now let me show you an example how do
we construct sunflower free families so
let's
focus and i think about three so i want
a set system that does not have a
threesome flower so here's one way to do
it
so my universe is going to have two
times w elements or two w elements
but i'm going to arrange them in a grid
where the height is two and the width is
w
and i'm going to take all the sets of
the following form in every column
choose one of the two elements
okay so i claim that first of all i have
two to the w
sets here but they do not have a
threesome flower why because in every
column if you have a three sunflower
then either all elements have to be
distinct or the same well they can't all
be distinct or they must be the same
so in fact they must be the same in all
columns so it must be the same set
repeated three times
so if this wasn't clear just verify to
yourself that this specific example
does not have a threesome flower so
there is a set system of such two to the
w
which is not three sunflower and the
conjecture is that maybe replacing this
two with a large constant a hundred
maybe every family of hundreds of w sets
does not contain a situation flower but
we do not know
it's a conjecture it's a sunflower
conjunction
okay now i have one slide about this
early semi-d
settings because i think it's
interesting for some applications
so here we're thinking about the set
system where we don't bound the side of
the sets
but instead we're saying that the only n
elements
and turns out this is actually a special
case of the election of the sunflower
both lemma and conjecture
so the sunflower lemma implies the
following results
if my set system is really close to
maxima so 2 to the l is all the sets i
could have
so it's two to them but i'm saving some
constant root n in the exponent
then it must contain an outside flower
and this concept depends on how
so you can prove that just by a simple
reduction from the
sunflower lemma and similarly by
reduction from the conjecture sunflower
conjecture
you said that actually even if you are
you can save much more conserve
something linear in n and not linear in
root n
and still you must contain the sunflower
and the nice thing about this other
summary is set in in fact we know this
is true
only for r equal to three so eric
nusland proved about two or three years
ago
that the early summer the sun flower
conjecture is true for i equal to three
and the proof is algebraic now i'm
assuming many of you have heard about
this resolution of the cap set problem
several years ago and what nestlin uses
a variant of the same proof technique to
prove
this result as well but the proof
doesn't seem
so far to generalize for all being four
five or any number more than three
so so far we only know that this
conjecture is two for three but not for
four
so that's very there's a very
tantalizing question
can this algebraic proof technique be
generalized to other problems
but this is not going to be the type of
the the proof i'm going to present today
will not be algebraic use of more
[ __ ] softer proof it'll be easier to
to modify so usually one you know
algebraically
that's one general meta comment i would
say algebraic proofs are like magic
right when they work they work amazingly
well they give you very nice succinct
proofs
for whatever you're trying to prove but
when they don't work because they fail
completely
and it's usually it's very hard to
modify your dubai pools to get them to
work in
other variants while you know when you
have
softer techniques sometimes you know the
puffs are messier maybe you don't get
tight bound sometimes
but they're usually easier to modify and
get it to work in other settings
and the proof i'll show you today will
not be on dubai
yes can you uh mention so the sunflower
lemma implies these parameters what is
known if with the current uh
knowledge this is a sunflower lemma so
the sunflower conjecture what does it
imply
so this so the sunflower conjunction
implies the bond i have here that the
optimal boundaries and my
the exponent is n minus c n okay okay
and the result i'll tell you about in a
bit would prove n minus
c times n over log n okay good what do
you say is n
any more questions
yeah okay when more people should ask
questions
not just
it's very it's very clear so far so good
perfect
so what's the result i want to tell you
about so we have this of again from now
on we're just going to switch this
radar setup or the setup size w and to
be concrete in this talk i'll focus on
finding the three sunflower and you'll
see the three is not nothing there's
nothing magical about three channels of
four and five and six and so on
and so here's what we know so the
sunflower level i told you about
gives this bound of w factorial times 2
to the w which is asymptotically
something like
w to the power of w and there were two
improvements
since the 60s so kostoska about 20 years
ago improved the exponent
by some other terms and then about two
years ago fukuyama had the proof
that improve the the exponent by some
constant
and the new bond i'll tell you about
improves the base to something like log
w
so now what we know this is true if the
set system is
something like log w instead of w
so we're getting closer to the
conjecture bound but not quite there yet
and if you sort of want to talk about
the results in slightly more detail
so the what we proved this was in this
work with a
ryan elwice and kevin wu and japan zhang
with the following bound
well we had this r log w bar that we
were trying to get and and you'll see
later why this is like a natural barrier
for our techniques
but somehow we had to suffer this
annoying lower order term here
that somehow we couldn't get rid of and
then there was this follow-up work
by frankston khan narayanan and park
that they actually were able to remove
this low of the term
and and they got this boundaries of the
best we know so far which is some
constant
and the reason they really cared about
this was not because of the sunflower
conjecture but because they were
realizing the same techniques actually
proves another conjecture
which was called the rational
expectation conjecture of telegram
i'll tell you a bit about this later on
in this talk when you see some of the
techniques that come up and but i'll say
one one word about this now it's
basically
this conjecture once you prove it allow
you to reduce many
of the questions in random graph theory
to basically simple calculations
so if you want to ask questions like if
you have a random graph what is the edge
what is the threshold
for finding a matching or a hamiltonian
cycle or whatever
thing you're interested in so before
people had a very complicated ad hoc
proofs
and now once this conjecture is proven
it just reduces of simple calculations
for different problems so i think this
was very nice i didn't know but it's
conjecture it was very nice to learn
about this
it was even nicer to realize that our
techniques on once improved them
actually pull this conjecture and then
there'll be sort of new two new proofs
of the same
same bound so anupra proved less here
he was able to simplify the proof using
the information theory
and then recently about twice the
resource of terry tau gave an
alternative proof
for again given the same ones also using
information theory in slightly different
ways
so now we have maybe four proofs for the
same
um same results and i think it's useful
because once you have different proofs
it may be makes it easier to think well
how can they maybe get better
better about right so this is very
useful having different proofs for the
same result
okay but the one i'll tell you about
today is mostly this one
and and i think
it's conceptually it's easier to
understand
so now let's talk about the proof
so again just remember what we're trying
to prove here
so we're trying to show that every large
enough set system
for all the sets of size w must contain
a three sunflower
and i'm going to use the following
notation a w set system
so a w set is a set of size w with w
elements
a w set system is a set system in favor
of sets
with all the sets of size w and what
we're going to prove with the following
slightly weaker bound
where every w set of size logged out to
the order w
contains the streets and flowers so i
mean so what you what you really wanted
was to put this
all to one but we don't care it's going
to have two or three here but the profit
will be slightly easier
that's what i want to prove to you and
again the high level approach we're
gonna take the following we're gonna use
two main ideas
structure versus randomness and this
bridge between tcat and math and in
particular as we'll see
later on in this talk they're going to
be a very natural
connection between set systems that we
study
in combinatorics and these objects
called dnfs
disjunctive normal forms that are widely
studied in tcs
and i'll explain what they are when they
come up but this connection was very
very
useful for us for deriving this result
so first of all structure versus
roundness
so now it's actually a very good time to
actually tell you the proof of the
sunflower lemma
that the erdogan radar pulled 60 years
ago and the proficiency is very very
simple it actually was going to
completely fit in this one slide
so here's the bond that we want to prove
i have a set system
that has a set of size w its size is
more than w factorial to the w
it must contain a threesome flower
so the possible induction on w and the
first step
is this simple observation that if my
set system contains
three disjoint sets i'm done why because
three disjoint sets
correspond to a sunflower with an empty
kernel
like in the sunflower we are not
requiring the kernel to be in an empty
remember the kernel
are all the elements that are common to
all the three sets
well if all the threes are disjoint then
there are trivial sunflower
so we are done so otherwise i'm claiming
that there are two sets in f whose union
must intersect all other sets in the
family why
take one set now if all the sets
intersected you're done
otherwise a second set this joint for me
take it now i have two sets
now by assumption there is no third set
this joint for both these two
so every other set must intersect one of
these two sets
so the union intersects all sets in the
set system
so what did i find i find the union of
two sets
well had at most two w elements
so one of these two elements must belong
to many many sets so i have two w
elements
that hit all sets in the stat system
right
every set in my set system contains at
least one of these two w elements
so let's take the element that belongs
to the largest number of sets in the
stat system
so just by basically union boundary
pigeonhole or whatever
there is an element that belongs to at
least one of the two w
fraction of sets in the state system so
let's take this element and take all
these sets
now now i i reduced my state system by
factor two w
but the benefit is now all the sets in
my set system
contain this one element so i can remove
it
now all the sets of size w minus one and
i can use induction
right there you see to these sets and
then use induction for double minus one
and you see the bound that you get is
two w times two w minus one
times two double minus two and so on so
you get exactly this bound
w factorials times two to w so we're
done that's the proof
we're done the proof is very very simple
and the question is well how can we hope
to do better so actually to see that i
want to introduce one notion
and then show this proof again using
this new language that's gonna maybe
hint how we can hopefully do better
so what i need is this one definition
called the link
so i have a set system f and i have a
set t
that is some arbitrary set not
necessarily in the set system
and we need this very very important
definition of a link
so the link of the set system f at the
set is the following set system
so i take all the sets in my set system
that contain tsa subset
and just for literally subset means
subset of equal always so
subs are equal and i take all the sets
and then i remove t from them
so just to make sure that you all
understand this i have a couple of
examples here
so if my set system is this set system
this is five sets
and then looking at the link of the set
one
so i take all the sets that contain one
so it's one two
and one three five and i remove one from
both of them so i get the sets two and
three five
and if you look in the link of the set 2
3 then i take all the sets content both
two and three so i have two three four
and two three six and then i move to
institution both of these four and six
so this is a link
and now what we need is the following
observation
it's very simple but very very powerful
if a link contains a three sunflower
then the original set system must also
contain a three sunflower
why but if a link ft contains a
threesome flower
then here the three sunflower s one
minus t this two minus t
is three minus t so if i just add t
to all of them i just empty to the
kernel the original sets s 1 s 2 3
are also starting so it's actually it
shows that if if for some reason it's
going to be easier
to find the sunflower inside the link
then we can reduce to a link and find a
three sunflower there
okay so now given this definition this
observation
let's go back to the spoof of the
sunflower lemma so i'm going to put the
same
sunflower lemon again using this link
terminology
so again the proof is by induction w and
now i'm going to do it in the other
direction what i will
assume there's an element x such that
the link
of x the single element is pretty big
as is more than f 2w in this case i'll
restrict to this link and use an
induction
for w minus 1. so so if there is a large
link of a single element
then we use induction otherwise
what we're going to prove to you that
there is no large link of a single
element
then your set system must contain three
disjoint sets
so we're done let's take a trivial
sunflower
and the proof is exactly the same as
before but just for
completeness i wrote this here so let's
go through it quickly
so take any set in the set system
any element in it by assumption the link
is small it contains
fewer than f of two w sets
so totally how many sets does s1
intersect it has w
elements each one intersects that many
sets so just union bound
it intersects less than half the set in
the stat system in particular there must
be another set in the
system disjoint from s1 take it by the
same argument
s2 also intersects less than half the
set in the same system
so overall there must be a set of three
this is joined from both f1 and s2
and we're done okay so it's basically
the same proof as before
just in the counter positive form right
but now that we've seen the proof in
this language it's of hints
how can we hope to improve this
so what can we hope to do well why just
look on links of a single element
it seems very restrictive why not look
on links of more than one element
that's what we're going to do so
see you that's our goal is going to be
to prove the following results
if f is a w set system what we want to
prove is for some parameter k it will
try to optimize
if f has more than k to the w sets it
must contain a threesome flower
and what we're going to well the
sunflower lemma as we said use links of
size one
and use induction for w minus one but
we're going to use larger links
so what we're going to say that well
what is a structured case
there is some link that is big
so assume there is a set t such that the
link of this set t
meaning all the satin statistics and
containing this subset
they have many of them what is many more
than whatever this parameter
okay we're trying to get to the power
double minus t
well like i'm claiming in this case we
can just use induction right it's the
same
statement so we can just use induction
here
so the so the random case would be
what if no link is big so the sunflower
lemma
used the assumption that no link of size
1 is too big
but now we're going to have this
stronger assumption that no link is too
big yes sorry
go ahead uh yeah so you have k is k of w
so you got to be a little bit careful
that uh k doesn't
you know as a function of w isn't too
bizarre for this
yes so you for example you want k to be
increasingly w
so k you want k of you want to say
increase w k cannot decrease
that's that's all the things you really
need here okay
okay weekly increase in w sure
thanks oh i think there's a question in
the q and a now
so it's uh with the answer live here
both proofs of the sunflower lemma uh
generalized naturally to our more than
three yes everything generalized to are
more than three
in a very natural way and i'm just using
i equal to three here because it's just
easier to explain but everything there's
gonna be exactly one point where three
is going to come up and then like and
i'll show you what this is
so yeah so far i was in general like
this
okay so now let's let's define more
specifically this pseudo-random case
here
but basically no link is too big
so we have the following definition a
set system is
case spread if the following condition
holds
for all links all sets t if i
look on the size of the link f t it is
much it is much smaller than the set of
f and by how much by a factor of k to
the t
so there is exponential decay in the
link size well the larger i choose
t the smaller the link gets
okay and crucially we'll need this
assumption for all
sets t so the the sunflower lemon proof
is just a city of size one
but we will use t altis okay so again
the larger i choose k the most of the
random it is the
they shrink faster
so the sunflower let me show that if k
is more than two w
then f contains 3 disjoint sets in fact
they only needed
t of size 1 here but what we're going to
prove that if we used all ts
we can improve the bond from linear and
w to logarithmic w
so that's going to be the main technical
part we're going to prove that if
we contain more than if k is more than
log w
roughly and and for all sets t
the link shrink by this with the base of
the exponent being k
then your set system must contain 3d
join sets
okay so now it's going to be a good
point to
talk about how we're going to hope to
prove that and here we're going to
connect set systems and dnfs
so every one slide introducing the nf's
if some people here in the audience
may be coming more from like a pure math
background maybe you haven't seen them
or forgot what they are but i do think
we teach them in discrete math
um so dnf is an o
of end of literals so a literal
is a verbal it's negation a term
is an end of literal so here's an end
and here's an end and he has an end
is a term and when we owe them we call
this a dnf
and they're going to be one parameter
that's important here in this stock
which is called the width of the dnf
width of a dnf is a maximum number of
verbals
appearing in a term like this example is
three the width of this dnf e3
and in that we will need some
restriction of the dnf that would
naturally correspond to that system
which is a monotone dnf so modern dnf
just means
there are no negated variables so this
should be non-negative variables not
terms
so meaning i only have positive
variables like x1 and x3 it's like i
don't allow negation
variables okay this is a month on dnf
and i'm claiming that a monotone dnf
naturally corresponds to a set system
and maybe the easiest way to see this by
this
example so here's a set system you know
three sets
and basically i translate every set into
the corresponding end of variable so the
set 1 to 3
would correspond to x1 and x2 and x3 and
the set
345 would correspond to the term x3 and
x4 x5 and so on
so it is very nice correspondence
but i mean so far it seems like sort of
abstract nonsense just like
two different ways of writing lists of
numbers so i want to claim that there is
actually a deeper connection
between set systems and dnf's not just
two different ways of writing lists of
numbers and
this would come from the following
observation that when you
think about dnfs the natural question
that come up
if you think well what do we typically
try to analyze about dnfs
coming from the cs perspective and one
very natural thing is asking well
given a dnf how many satisfied
assignments does it have if i
set x one x two experience onto two or
false
how many choices do i have making this
dnf
true or an equivalent way if i choose
these variables randomly true or false
what's the probability that's going to
be true
and we would actually need this for
something that's called the p bias
distribution
where we will choose in x and zero one
they think of the v was false and one is
true
so false or true there are one to the n
we're i'm saying
it's not 50 50 but there is some bias
towards some direction
so i'm going to use p by s to say the
probability x i is 1
is p and p will typically be something
much less than a half so i'm going to
choose
my every x i to be true with some small
probability p
and i'm asking let's try to analyze the
probability that this dnf this month
indianapolis is satisfied
okay this will somehow be important for
us
and i think the fact that this is a
natural question to ask about dnfs
would suggest that it might also be a
natural question to ask about set
systems
so and one definition here
so i'm using curly f capital f4 set
system and small f
for this corresponding monotone dnf
and i'm going to say this dnf is p q
satisfying so p and q two numbers
between zero and one
if the following thing is true i'm
choosing my inputs coming from this p
bus distribution and every exercise one
probability p independently
and the probability is dnf is one is
pretty big it's more than one minus q
okay so the smaller p is it's
harder to specify the dnf and the
smaller q is i'm requiring more from
this dnf so a smaller pins molecule
is a stronger condition
and now let's see what this translates
to when i'm going back from this
monotone dnf setting
to this set system setting so first of
all what is this p by distribution with
just a p by distribution of a sets
right so i'm choosing a subset of my
universe let's see if a universe is
n this is a random set in my
universe where every element is included
with probability p independent that's a
p by distribution
what does it mean that the set system is
peak you're satisfied with the following
condition
so i want some term in my dna to be
satisfied
a term is satisfied if all elements are
one so i'm asking what's the probability
that there exists a set in my set system
that is completely contained in w
right w are all the elements that were
set to one
and the dnf is satisfied if there is
exists a term where all the elements are
set to one
so equivalently there is a set in the
set system
completely contain this doubly
so i'm claiming that now this question
which might not be a natural question to
ask if you're studying such systems
becomes natural once we review them in
this alternative way
as monotone dnfs so the question we're
going to ask about set systems is the
following question
choose a random set that value from some
p bass distribution
what's the probability that they
completely cover some set in my set
system
and now here's a very natural question
what does this have to do with
sunflowers this seems completely
you know out of nowhere how can i hope
to you
anything like that just study sunflowers
so i want to show you that actually a
very deep connection between these
questions and sunflowers
so i want to prove to the following and
this will sort of connect these things
together
so again i i copy the definition at the
top and i'm going to set p and q to be a
third
so i'm going to say if f is one third
one third satisfying
then it must contain three disjoint sets
you know what is one third one that is
fine so i'm choosing w from this u one
third so every element is included
probably one third independently
and i want the probability more than two
thirds i'm going to contain a set of
message
and i'm claiming if this happens this
type of probabilistic statement
then your set system must contain three
disjoint sets
and the proof is simple it's going to
fit in the bottom of this slide i'll
show this in a second
but i just want to make one comment here
that this is one way of of connecting
i would say some soft techniques about
you know some probabilistic statements
where we have parameters like p and q we
could adjust
to a very combinatorial question about
property
about a set system containing 3d journal
sets
so this is why sometimes it is useful to
try to use more software techniques
you can adjust parameters because they
give greater flexibility
like for example this was one question
somebody asked before if i wanted to
change this
three to a four if i wanted for these
join sets i'll just change those two
parts to work one quarter one quarter
and everything would generalize
um okay now let's see the fourth
so i'm going to consider the following
experiment i'm going to take all the
elements
in the universe and i'm going to
randomly color each element with one of
three colors either red
or green or blue okay that's my
experiment
and i'm going to look at the marginal
distribution so i'm claiming that the
red
marginal distribution is exactly u one
third right but every element is colored
red
with probably one third and the same is
true for green and blue
so of course not in the lg and b are not
independent
but the marginal distribution of r g and
b each one is u one third
and now let's ask what's a probability
that my set system
contains a set where all the elements in
the set will color red so i call this a
red set
well it's exactly the same as asking
what's a probability
that there's a set in my set system that
is contained
entirely contained inside the set of red
elements
now because r has marginal u one third
because i assume this is one third one
third satisfying
this probability is more than one minus
q more than two thirds
right just by definition and similarly
for green and blue
right with both green and blue have
marginally one-third
so what do we get probably more than
two-thirds i could turn a red set
a green set and a blue set so by union
bound
with positive probability my set system
contains
a red set a green set and a blue set
so in particular the three sets must be
disjoint because obviously right like
all the elements of the first little
color was red and the second green and
third was both
they can't have common elements so
that's it that's a proof
so actually now is a good time for
people to maybe stare on this slide for
like you know
10 20 seconds and see if you have any
questions
because i mean although that technically
it's simple
conceptually sure that we can reduce
from these questions
this combinatorial question about
finding 3d join sets
to solve probabilistic statement of sure
that the set system is satisfying
so maybe maybe i'll give people some
time to digest this and see if they have
any
questions
um one thing about
going back to comment on soft techniques
um and
this proof typically soft techniques
uh they tell you that a lot of a large
number of some combinatorial structures
exist
so does your proof also tell you a whole
number of sunflowers exist
yeah yes but for this you don't need to
use it in black box because you find a
sulfur you remove it you keep doing it
again again
okay this is fluid in any room this is a
type of question right you find the
structures usually tiny you remove it
and keep going right
okay but the tech proof itself doesn't
surprising that somehow it's a soft
technique but it actually
is proving exactly one uh
object yes now but actually what it
shows
is something different that the
sunflowers are not sort of you know
very special so that even if i choose
like a random coloring you're going to
find like
monochromatic sunflowers
or in this case so actually what this
would prove if you if you could if you
combine this with this structural part
that we removed
before so if you put them together
because if i randomly call all my
elements red green and blue
and if i change this one third let's say
to one six or something so i changed to
some other
then with high probability 50
you're going to find the sunflower where
the pet or the kernel of course they can
control its
coloring but the petals are going to be
one red
one green and one blue okay
yeah yeah um
okay i have a question regarding this
link definition so i guess this is
familiar from other contexts
one one way to to think of the link is
that if you
view um you know the the set system is
as a polynomial right that every
like uh set corresponds to a monomial
then the
link is just the derivative right you
take uh yes
yes take the derivative of respect to
this is this
useful like this view of polynomial i
mean i think
i think it might be useful in some
settings not not for this specific
proof we have because the proof of is
not your bike at all but yeah these
things are useful in other settings
but i don't see why to be useful here
yeah i'm also not seeing it but i don't
know i thought maybe
you could it's is the same thing that
you connect it to dns maybe you can
connect it to pull yourself
okay maybe yeah i don't know but then
with pronunciation you add them up right
you sum them and you ask them about the
sum
and here's some how it's crucial about
the o and not the sum
right so it would exist in something not
something happening for many things so
that's
actually important here by the way links
if you're aware they come up a lot in
when you study
high dimensional complexes or
hypergraphs
high dimension expanders which is a very
recent and trendy topic so they're very
very
they come up a lot they're also
understanding link structure and how
this affects
you know hypergraph structure so it's
not a
i mean we did not invent this term it's
a very common term and hypograph
yes there's another question in the
oh the questions thank you so so
what does algebraic proof mean exactly
okay so by
when i say algebraic proof i mean you
usually it means you define some
polynomial
and you say something old this
polynomial has certain
root structure or whatever so it must be
something i don't know i don't have a
very precise answer but like as examples
for example disprove the cap set
conjecture
is algebraic um
i don't know of the proofs of the joints
conjecture you know that it was algebra
usually using polynomials somehow the
proof of using the fact that polynomials
have some sort of
the roots cannot be arbitrary
usually this is what i mean by algebraic
using something about polynomials or
matrices or some something linear
algebraic
okay so maybe i'll continue
so here's the main technical results
that we prove in this work which is this
spread set systems are satisfying and
here are the technical
details you know and first i call the
definition so we have a w set system
so all the sets of size w or w
it is k spread meaning that the links
decrease exponentially fast with this
base k
and again pq satisfying means that
if you choose w for this p bus
distribution
then the master with high probability of
the set
contains the dub in w in the elements
which also even if you choose each
element only a third of the elements
the type probability wouldn't contain
your statistics within the sensor
and what you prove is for k something
like log w
if you're a k spread then you are like
one third one third so that's fine
but if you want to change one third one
third let's say one over ten one over
ten
you just change some constants here in a
way they're not specified
so just constants and
and we actually even understand the
right dependence on p and q
i'm not going to talk about this here
but you know in this sort of later works
of
uh frank cena and the one that the loop
also gave they actually get a tight
dependence on p and q up to constants
so we understand everything there
completely and i'm going to give you
some examples to the end of the talk
showing why this type of approach
will not get better than log w right so
it turns out for this
type of result log w is the right answer
and not constant and then we have some
examples for that that you'll see later
on
so this is what i want to prove to you
um
so just to recap where we are so far
so we're assuming that the set system
has size let's say k to the w
and one k w for k being something like
log w
there is a structure case and a pseudo
random case the structure case says the
set system has a large link
in this case there is a set t where the
link is more than f over k to the t
so we just induction for ft you see this
is what paul was asking before
k is increasing double so i say increase
to a link the k n is even smaller
so in particular satisfy this condition
there is induction
the other case is this to the random
case where all the links are small
so this we call this case spread
condition this is just a complement of
that
all the links are smaller decay
exponentially flush with space k
we had this lemma that we need to prove
showing that this
is one third one third is fine we
haven't proven that yet that's a one
missing ingredient but we've seen a
coloring of that showing that
f must contain three disjoint sets and
hence
here's the trivial sunblock so that's a
whole proof and the only ingredient
missing is this lemma here so we're
gonna do in the thing the second part of
the talk
and actually i think now might be a good
time i think i think we're looking
forward to brexit now could be a good
time for a break
and and i'll continue in the second half
okay so let's uh take a
10 minute break i guess uh if you want
to stick around in the break you can or
otherwise you can
um you know have some coffee or
take a short break and let's see again
in
10 minutes
so are we continuing the live streaming
during the break
or not what's the rules
pause it i guess livestream stays on i
think
uh you could stop pause the recording if
you want to pause the recording
yeah i i i pause yeah i think it's
better to pause it and then have the
second half piece of
i think i thought you did for the
previous two talks and i think it was
very good but the first half is not more
high level in the second half is maybe
slightly more technical
it's going to be the same thing here
trying to follow the same approach
right by the way things that somehow
somebody
so abhishey these recordings are they
posted somewhere some oh
i see someone who wrote my name wrong so
but i don't see how to fix this
didn't set it up so it's it's in the
simon's website
uh oh yes yes i can i can post a link in
the chat
yeah we should fix uh shahar's name
yeah i don't i don't have an opportunity
of renaming
somebody
uh on top of the zoom uh
is the way the zoom is set up on top uh
yeah
and usually i have an option of changing
the name but now it doesn't let me
change the name
all right i can i can add the profile
picture but they cannot change the name
so
anyway if it's too hard then it's fine i
can
okay okay good okay
yes so okay i'll post the link for the
entire series and then
you can
right for individual talks just press
the links
and i think
already we have the the talk of that you
just
finished like already stock is there so
really yes that's amazing how did this
happen
i don't know
when you said the proof for the colors
it sounded like this story uh
so it's something about the five
colored balloons and then like each each
boy or girl gets one of them and like
all of them the only question is
why right
should we resume yes perfect so can i
everything is
set up yep i hope yeah
yeah okay perfect okay so let's continue
so welcome back everybody and
so let me remind you where we stand so
our goal is basically to put this one
missing piece which is this lemma here
yeah okay so here's what we want to
prove we want to prove
that a spreadsheet system which reminds
us
this sort of type of pseudo-random stat
system
how satisfying meaning that the random
sparse set
contains a certain message system with
high probability
and because we have this equivalence
between set systems and dnfs
an equivalent way of thinking about this
is true the pseudorandom dnf
is satisfied with hyperability
and we know that i mean if people come
from the tcs background probably you
know that
we know from the classical works of
hasta then and others know as bove and
paul beam
that's random restrictions simplified
dnfs and what we're going to show that
if you
sort of say that my dnf is not arbitrary
pseudorandom in a certain way
you can do some mild running
restrictions so again if you're coming
from the tcs background maybe you've
heard about these topics if you haven't
then maybe they're all new but i'm going
to explain everything
um so now random restrictions and dnfs
and by the way if you if you heard my
ccc talk
last week that's going to be basically
part of the token ccc so you might have
heard about this already but then at the
end they have some new stuff so
you might want to hang around for that
um
so now i'm going to just be thinking
about dnfs
and and and then present everything with
respect to dnf's and then at the very
end i'll tell you how this connects back
to set systems
but i think it's more natural i mean at
least for me it's more natural
to present this in in in length of dnfs
so we have a boolean function f so
function of nb
is one bit and what we're going to study
are restrictions and the restriction is
where we take some
inputs in zero one and we and and we fix
them some
inputs and we fix them to zero one some
some
some input value and the rest we keep
free so this is what i'm doing by star
so a restriction is low
in zero one star to the n where the
stars are all the alive variables the
one haven't fixed so far
and zero ones are the one we fixed to
inputs
and in particular we're going to study
random restrictions where we do it
randomly
so we randomly choose some p fraction of
the inputs
and we're going to fix them to random
values zero one
and there are two ways you can do random
restrictions one is you say well i fix
sap is one percent i want to choose
exactly one percent of my input and fix
them
to zero one and the rest are key free
that's one value and the other variant
is that we just do it independently for
each coordinates
and this provides our model is basically
the same i mean you can move from one to
the other so
it doesn't really matter which one we're
using
and and the goal for us to show this is
high probability somehow the functions
simplify but not just this
in general for random restrictions so if
you have a function
and you fix some inputs 0 and 1 you're
hoping the function becomes
simpler and
here's like a classical so if you know
i'm just looking one
here's a classical result from
complexity theory
it says the following thing remember we
have dna
and our dnfs come from we actually have
monotone dnf's coming from set systems
but there'll be not but because it's
equivalent just think about the regular
dnf's not
this monotone restriction it doesn't
really matter
so either with wdnf and i'm going to
choose a p random restriction
you know p the fraction of variables i
fixed 0 1
with p being very very close to 1
something like 1 minus 1 over 10 w
so not quite one one would be fixing
everything but it's very close to one
so i fix all but something like one over
w fraction of inputs
and i'll denote the simplified functions
simplify dnf by
f rho and the switching lemma
which was first proved by hasta the lens
of there was a simplified proof by
rosboro then by beam
is that by setting this p very close to
one
this restriction becomes very very
simple in particular there's some
complexity parameter called decision
tree depth and with high probability it
is very small
but i'm just going to tell you about
what's called the baby version of that
that says
with high probability your restricted
dnf becomes constant
so what we do here we have a dnf with w
we fixed
almost all of the variables to constant
zero one
and with high probability my dnf is now
constant like
even though i still have like one of a w
fraction of variables that are alive
we do not need to know them like the
other variables
already fix the value of the dna and i
want to show you the proof of this lemma
because the proof of it
uses encoding argument and we're going
to use a similar encoding argument for
what we'll try to do
when we're going to study pseudorandom
dns so i want to show you the proof
in fact in the parameters i said you
could even get something slightly better
but just half at 90 percent so the
profit has
two definitions so let me denote by rfk
all the restrictions were exactly case
styles
the exactly k stars so i choose k
variables i set them
keep them alive all the other inputs i
set them randomly to be zero one
fifty fifty seven these restrictions
and that bad decay are all these
restrictions where
the dnf did not become cons these are
the bad restrictions
but what you want to show that these bad
restrictions are a small fraction of all
the restrictions
um
sorry one second it is
there is a leak in the the pool is
leaking
sorry
anyways let me continue um so the way
we're going to do it is we're going to
find an encoding
we're going to encode bad restrictions
bad k
into some set it's going to be smaller
than all the restrictions
it's going to be an injective encoding
so this would show that bad k
is a small fraction of all the
restrictions and what is this said well
it's going to be all the 2 parts the
first part all the restrictions what i'm
saying
there are not cased alive variables but
k minus one so one variable less
i'm fixing one more variable and another
part which is an index between one and w
so this is just a set of one up to w
and why is this good for us with
remember the way we set k is we
the number of verbs we keep alive was n
over 10 double
so one of the ten double fractions
elements and if you do the calculation
because we set already almost all of the
inputs to 0 and 1
setting one more input restricts the
number of
restrictions by a lot it decreases them
by a factor of 10 double
so fixing one more variable really kills
a lot of restrictions
so even if i say add another piece of
information says w options
we get this number of bad elements that
restrictions
is at most 10 of all the restrictions so
we get this
probability so the only question is how
do we define this encoding that's where
all the magic happens
so what you want to encode is a bad
restriction as a pair
another by the restriction row prime
another restriction raw prime not
slightly bad
restriction but where we have only k
minus one
a live variables and an index between
one and w
so here's my dnf and i have the terms
sorted in some arbitrary order and we
define a process so the first process
will say let's take f of rho
so my dnf when i fix the restriction
because it's bad
it means well my dnf is not constant
some terms are not killed and they're
not fixed one those are still alive
let's take the first one and let's take
the first variable that is a star in it
has to be at least one and
define row prime in the following way
take row and fix this variable xj to a
value b
zero one so that this term is not killed
meaning if this xj appears in ti
positively i'm going to set it to
one if it if not x j plus c we're going
to set this to zero so t i
is not killed it either survives or
becomes satisfied
so this is how i define row prime and
then the index is just going to be the
following thing
i take all the variables of ti and
apriori we sort them in some order
and tell which one of them is xj so it's
some number between one and w
that is the index of the index in all
the variables of ti
this specific variable xj i chose so
it's just
it's in the same range and that's
encoding
and all that we need to show that this
encoding is injective
and we're going to show it by showing
this algorithmic that you can given this
output we can reverse the process and
compute the input so given row prime and
the index you can just compute rho
so let's just do that so let's just
conject it
so first of all i'm claiming given rho
prime
i can find t i y i'm just going to ask
well what's the first
term that is either satisfied or not
killed
in f under row prime well t i was the
first in f row
and then this x j to the specific value
keeps this not killed so ti is going to
be this first one also under row prime
and now so i found t i now given t i and
not now i don't know t i
i know the index of x j in the variable
so i can find x j
so now i know t i and x j and now i can
just recover
row prime because i just set
now here to get from row to row prime i
set xj to some value
to go back and just set it back to star
and i'm done
so this is an invertible process and
because it's invertible process
it's injective so this this finishes the
proof
right so the main thing that we did here
the encode
bed restrictions in some way that allow
us to bound the number of bad
restrictions
and now you can ask so this is the lemma
that we proved here
switching this baby version of the
switching lemma and you can ask is this
tight
do you really choose p very very close
to one do you need to fix
almost all of the variables
and that's a problem sometimes like in
some applications we really want to fix
only
half the elements or one percent of the
elements not almost all the elements
do we need that and the other is yes so
here's an example
this example is called the tribes
function it's basically a read once dnf
so i have it's a dnf with two to the w
terms
and they're all these joints so each
each term is an end of w verbs
and you can actually do a calculation
and see that to make it
constant you really need to fix almost
all of the inputs
otherwise does not become constant so it
shows that the switching lemma
or even the baby version of the
switching lemma are tight so if you make
no assumptions in dnfs
you really need to fix almost all of the
inputs
so you need to make some assumptions on
your dnf to hope to do better
so now i want to say well we can
analyze milder random restrictions that
fix only a small threshold of the inputs
if we assume that dnf is still the
random so here's my dnf
and i'm going to say that the dnf is k
spread which is the same definition as
before
if it satisfy the following condition
every t variables every number t
every t variables appear together
in at most m over k to the t terms
okay so i have m terms in total
and this corresponds to the m sets i
have before
this is the same as this committed the
links shrink right
so take t variables i take the link
defined by the t variables
all these terms contain these two
variables and there should be
a small fraction of them this should
decrease by a factor of k to the t
and that's the same as the underlying
set system being k spread
you know for monotone dnfs we just had
this natural correspondence between
variables and elements if it's
non-monotone dnf you get the same thing
but you need an element for x i not x i
so you have two l
two you have both of them but the same
thing so it's the same condition as
before but now we just view it from a
dnf perspective
and not from the statism perspective
it's exactly the same condition
so just to make sure we're on the same
page you have this very simple claim
here
this just to make sure that we all
understand what's going on here all the
parameters
if a dnf has a width w and is
k spread then it's proved that the
number of terms has to be at least some
number
at least k to the w it cannot be very
small
so why well here's the answer
take a single term a single term
contains w variables but i know that you
have a single term t is w
take w variables the number of terms
should be at most m over k to the w
but it's at least one so m should be at
least k to the w
right so you should at least make sure
that you just to see that the parameters
align
okay so going back to the stripes
example
it is not very spread it's only two
spread
so in that sense tribal example is not
pseudo-random enough
so what we're going to prove is that
the following theorem if
a dnf is k spread
where k is relatively big something like
log w
then p random restrictions are going to
make it constant high probability
so for example if i want p to be a third
which is what we need for this
three sunflower resolve results
then we need k to be something like
three log w
all right but then but again if you
think of ps a constant it should be
something like log w
so for example if i go back to the
stripes example we had before
and i want to make this case spread i
need to replace this
top fan in not to be two to the w terms
but k to the w terms
and then mild restrictions are going to
work so if you want
one picture in your mind for what is an
example
of a most of the random dnf is just
think about stripes about
the top of earnings not two to the w but
k okay but of course what we have is a
more general condition
we don't assume these terms are disjoint
we just assume that the
the links decrease faster this is what
we want to prove that's the same as the
dilemma we had before
and again in particular we can take p
very very close to zero here so we can
take restriction that fix only a small
fraction
of the inputs and by assuming that dnf
is to the right enough you can still
analyze
you know the probability that this dnf
becomes constant
yes so you call this a pseudorandom
property this case spread
do you have like a natural distribution
for which
the random behavior is case spread yeah
that's a very good question i mean i'm
not sure that's
precisely a thing but this sort of
morally corresponds to choosing sets
randomly in a
with the universe size somehow you maybe
you need the universe size to be k to
the w
and you choose random sets i think that
would give you that
so maybe the fact that you are choosing
like a lot of sets compared to their
size
right so it's sort of like more than yes
yes
yes exactly yes exactly yes
but also they don't somehow concentrate
on a few elements right
i mean you could have cases that all of
them would contain the same w
elements right so this won't help you
but i thought that you also had like an
example where the universe size is kind
of small and
yeah yeah i'll get to that at the end
i'll show that later on
yeah we have an example where we have
this condition or the universe has this
one but
i'll get to that in 20 minutes so if you
already seen this and you know what this
is going to but otherwise
i'll get to that in a bit
okay so this is what we want to prove
that we have
again think of p as some constant one
third or something
so if if f is k spread and you're like
something now and log w then then would
have probability that dnf is constant is
going to be satisfied sorry you have
already constant
and the main idea with if you fix even a
smaller number of inputs something like
p over log w
then this would reduce the width of the
dna from w to w over 2.
and actually this would be for most
terms or for some average width but but
ignore these are technical
issues so conceptually what you want to
say
we want to fix some small number of
inputs and reduce the width of the dnf
by facto
and turn that what you need to fix is p
of a log w and this log w here is why
this is log w because what we want to do
now is we want to repeat this
log w times if you repeat this log w
times
the width becomes zero and the dnf
becomes
constant so you want to repeat this log
w times which means we'll choose
this to be p over log w and this is the
main reason why we need to play this log
w
this is just the inverse of that right
that's true this is the inverse of that
but to get the constant you really need
this log w here or this log w in the
denominator
okay so now let's do that and then
that's a with reduction
step so we have a restriction
and we have a term some term that after
this restriction stays
alive so it's consistent with row and
typically because the row only fixes
like a small fraction of the elements we
expect a typical term
most of the variables in it will still
be alive a few might be
set to zero one by this restriction but
most of them can be alive
now here's a crucial definition this
term is compressible
if there is a term tj that satisfies two
properties
first of all given this restriction
and given ti the ti is true 3j is also
true so ti plus rho imply tj
so th tj might have some variables
inside ti
and some other variables inside the
registration it's consistent with both
so that's because it's been con system
but more crucially i want tj to have
small width
so tj should have less than half of w
alive variables stars another under the
restriction
so tj should be mostly
the variables in the resolution and have
at most half the variables in the styles
okay so this is what i mean that ta is
compressible so why is this useful
because if i have a compressible
term if we just replace ti with tj tj
some other term in my dnf they could say
well
under the restriction row instead of
asking for ti to be satisfied
let's just ask for tj to be satisfied
and this doesn't lose anything but now
the width
of this specific term went down to w
okay so under row we can replace the i
with to j
and the main claim that we're going to
show that most terms
you know dnf are compressible and in
fact you can even analyze the average
width rather than average with
decreasable effect after
but let's fast let's ignore this average
with
condition so you want to prove that and
again the proof is going to be in coding
argument
so what we want to do is we want to
encode so before we encoded our bed
restrictions
now we're going to encode the bed a
restriction and a bad term
so a restriction here and a term that is
bad in the sense that it is
consistent with row but it is not
compressible
so there is no tj tj doesn't exist how
can you can you
go back slide yes sure yeah i think this
is like maybe the
the most uh
you know new definitions that that maybe
were
posing but i have one question about it
so you're saying we can replace that
with tj
this is because we are thinking of like
right we're thinking of both of them
together right so
yeah we're trying to satisfy either t i
o t j right then t i o t j
or a bunch of other things if c is
satisfied then t
i would be satisfied so we can just
replace it but i keep going
another way around if ti satisfied then
tj is satisfied
so t i o t j has this fight so for i can
just remove t
i right because if i if i satisfy t i
then at some point on the way
heterosexuality just well
so ti is redundant so that you can sort
of
merge these two terms to one of them yes
yes yes
exactly i know this restriction you can
merge the intj together to a single term
to jj
very good yesterday this is maybe the
the one new definition here
so if there are any questions on this
compressible definition maybe not a good
time to ask
so one just one comment i mean you had
earlier said well typically ti without
only a
you know a p fraction of of things set
by rho
t j is not typical in that sense here
it's got half of it
set by row yes tj is not typical but you
know we have so many terms
much more than exponential in w
so that we expect some terms to be
atypical
so really we're trying to exploit the
fact that we have some atypical terms
here
and the dnf to satisfy dna to not
specify one term
so you can just restrict attention to
the atypical terms
there's a question in the q a oh perfect
thank you what does t i plus rho
mean okay so ti plus rho i just mean
if i assume that ti is true and i assume
that row is true
so i assume both of them are true so i
set all the variables to make ti
consistent
and row that's given and i'm asking does
this imply to j
so for example if a variable in ti is if
x1 is in the i
i'm going to set xoxo x 1 to 1. if i
have not x1
into i want to set x1 to 0. so i'm going
to set the variables in ti
so that ti becomes satisfied and because
ti and row are consistent there's no
no inconsistency here right so setting
all of row
the way row is given to me and setting t
is the verbs of t
so it's satisfied these two things are
consistent
so i'm setting at most w
new variables two values so that
you know i satisfy both ti and i'm
consists and i have a brother
so did this answer the question let's
see more questions
if you have multiple ti then the tj for
hdi might be jointly satisfiable with
other originality i be enjoying the
sense fiber
yes it could be that multiple ti have
the same tj
there's nothing against that anybody
remember in a dnf
i don't care if i satisfy one term or
ten thousand terms
once if i one term i'm done so to that
extent
we don't care if um if we satisfy
one or more than one term
that's that's a crucial aspect of the
dnf like for example a polynomial would
count things here we're not counting
we're saying either at least one or none
so there might be many many ti's with
the same dj that's fine
more questions
so i'll continue
then i want to encode again a
restriction in the term ti that is
consistent with this restriction but is
not compressible
in some way that's sure that these
numbers are small
so first i'll take row prime to be row
plus ti so again this is the same as we
had before
so we take the restriction row and then
we set all the variables in ti
that were not fixed by the restriction
so that they are all satisfied
this is row prime so i fixed at most w
new elements
now let t j be the first term
that is satisfied by rho prime now
t j um might be there is
such term because ti is one such term
but there might be other ones i don't
think the first one let's dj now let's
define
v to be all the common variables of t
intj
okay it might be none there might be
some so i'll take all these common
variables
and then define index one to be the
following thing i take
all the variables of tj so i know tj
v is some subset of this variable so i
index it
so tensor two to the w sets possible
subset this is one of two to the w
subsets
of the vowels of tj so i index it i
write the index fits
now that i know these common variables i
set fv
to be all the terms in my dnf
that contain v where these variables
appear in this term and here's where
we're going to use the fact that this is
if v is a big set then this this
dnf has much much fewer terms compared
to the original dna because the links
shrink fast
so index now in particular ti
to trying to compress is one of these
terms because
it had the variables v what is the
verbal ci here
so it's one of these terms and then if
it's one of these terms i just write the
index so in fva arbitrarily order them
and i tell you which index it is the
first one the second one the handles one
so on
that's going to be the second index and
lastly we need one more piece
to complete this picture which is is the
restriction row
on ti well we'll leave that also and i
just
write them all this is my encoding so my
including all the red parts here
is this new restriction row prime these
two indices
and this information s which is the what
happened this restriction row
under ti which path was stars
or not okay
now first of all let me show you why
given these four pieces of information
we can recover onti and then we'll do
calculation
why this actually compresses the size so
i claim that to recover here there's
nothing
deep going on just go through this
process one by one and just recover
everything let's see
so i can recover all prime i can recover
tj why
because i know rho prime is given to me
tj the first term
satisfied with raw private not ej now
given tj
i know the variables of dj i know the
index of v
here is index one so i can recover v
if i know v i no fv i know the index
of t i and f is i know t i
and finally i know if i know rho prime
and i know t
i so i know the new and i know
what was wrong yeah i know which verbs i
added to row prime
and i can just set them back to stars
and get back row so this will cover here
they're just going through this step
there's nothing
deep going on here so the interesting
part is coming
trying to understand why does this
actually compress information
let's do a calculation so so here on the
bottom i just wrote the encoding
argument
and now let's go through these steps so
the two main observations first of all
this may be the main one the fact that
ti is not compressible
means the ti and tj must have many
variables in common
why if tj and ti had very few verbs in
common
then tj would have been mostly in the
restriction part
so the number of stars in it would be
very small
so because ti is not compressible it
said that any tj
that is consistent with ti and
restriction
must have most of its variables in the
stars so particularly the first one
has this property so this is more than
enough value for two
because this is the way we define
compressible w over two
now the second part is that because
we're assuming this should be spread
sorry because we're assuming the f is k
spread
then we know that this link of v the set
of v
all the terms that contain v the much
much much fewer terms
compared to the full terms we shrink by
a factor of k to the size of v
and since the set of these w over two
this shrinks but most sketches double
over two
so we're going to use these two two
observations
so why let's do calculation first of all
how many objects are we trying to
compress overall
well the number of restrictions is our p
and anything
i'm here defining rpn to be all the
restrictions
where i fix pn variables
okay so rpn for this proof is all the
restrictions were
fixed p and where was this is the number
of rows i have in total
how many terms do you have in total m
because this is the number of pairs
overall not just a bad one all of them
how many bad ones do i have well for
this i'm just going to count the number
of restrictions
so what is a row prime row prime is a
restriction like row
where you fix w more variables so it's a
some restriction in rpn plus k but k
goes from 1 to w
so i fixed w more variables and
then you could do calculation and see
this at most rpn but now
it's more than rpn so this is a larger
number i divide by p to the wp is very
it's very small
so this is a larger number right so this
is unlike in the hearthstone switching i
mean has the switching lemma
because we fixed almost all of the
variables fixing a few more variables
decreases the number of restrictions
here's the opposite because in our
resolution we fixed
small number of variables we increase
the number of restrictions so we lose
so here we lose something but we're
going to recover that in the
spreadness part well the number of the
first index just two to the w sets
that's
something the number of the second index
is where we gain because then well how
many terms do i have consistent with
v at most fb at most this number
so at most m number of terms but now we
gain
much fewer terms this power term is
going to compete with this term
and then this last part is this
restriction as it was to the w these two
just some other terms you need to add
here
that's very interesting so what we need
to get this to work is we need the
products of all these terms
to be much less than this if we show
that most
pairs row and ti are
good for most restrictions most terms
can be compressed
so if you do the calculations here you
will see the way i set up the parameters
i need k to be something like one over p
squared
okay so you need k in this refrigerator
we set p to be something
like one over log w so k would need to
be something like w squared here
so this will give us this the bound i
promised you
if you optimize the parameters here then
you get very very close to one another p
but not quite so we lose some log lower
order terms but then there were the sort
of
follow-up works that were able to
improve these terms
so again this is what i promised you
this is a theoretical promise to you
that if k is something like log w of op
then and in your dnf is k spread then p
random restriction gonna make it
constant high probability
and now what is this approximate here
well the original proof we had lost some
log log terms here
but then instead of follow-up work by
frank's terminal
actually where to get this to be only a
constant so log w over v
and this is what in the reason they
needed to remove these log log terms
because this is the for this is the
phrase they actually need
to prove this fractional expectation
conjecture of telegram
again and this and what a new power
integrator approved is this
result this result they reproved
using information theory so what anup
did is analyze the same
encoding procedure but using enthalpy
instead of using counting
and what terry did is analyze a
different encoding procedure sort of but
implicitly
where basically here instead of using tj
to be the first terms this type of
alpine
somehow is choosing to be a random term
satisfied by a prime
but and then he somehow simplifies our
analysis using
enthalpy and you can read both of the
books
i mean anup has a paper on this in
theory has this
in his blog okay
now let me proceed the theorem as stated
is tight you cannot have to do better
in particular if you're hoping to use
spreadness you will never get beyond log
w
terms even if p is like a third constant
and here's an example
so what's the example so now i have a
small number of elements w times k
and i arrange them in a grid where i
have a w rows
in k columns and my here's my dnf so
every cell here is a variable will be
two or false
my dnf is the monotone dna this is the
following thing
in every row there should be at least
one
this is at least one okay since i want
to write this as a dnf so i'm going to
have a term
for every way of choosing an element in
a row
so i have k to the power w terms
it has with w because every term is just
a single element in every row
you can check it is k regular where k
spreads or you regularize the term
in a different incarnation of this paper
so when you see regular things spread
you need to fix this
k spread and
but you can do a calculation and see
that if i choose k to be something like
log w over p
then p random restrictions do not make
it constant
so this is types so i'm not going to do
the calculation here but it's a typical
question to make
okay so this shows that if you're hoping
to beat log w
you need to find a different approach
this theorem is tight
so just to summarize if we just think
about dnfs and for general dnfs
random restrictions need to fix almost
all of the variables to simplify the dnf
but if my dnf is super random so it is
spread
then it's enough to fix a small fraction
of the variables and if we go back to
set systems
so if you remember set systems
correspond
to monotone dnfs when there are
non-negated variables
well it turns out if you study monotone
dnfs
it's enough to consider the restrictions
that are not zero one stop but just one
star
just fix variables to once and then
you just go for the definitions the
proof is the same
then just a dnf becoming constant the
same as dnf becoming one
because it can become zero and then the
statistic is satisfied
so they're just following the
definitions i'm not going to do this
here but just the same
just sort of make sure the definitions
match
so the proof i showed you this more
general pull for dnfs
if you just if you just care about set
systems that you just care about modern
dnfs
it's enough to study this monotone
illustrations
where you never set verbs to deal but
then the same everything's the same
good so maybe now with the good time for
questions well here's
just summarizing the results we've seen
so we're studying w set systems we want
the sun flower size r
and i wrote here the bonds for the
sunflower lemon the conjunction what we
proved
or the improved bond for in the
follow-up works
and which is also the limitation of the
current technique
so i have several open problems i want
to present here
but maybe before that let's see if
people have any questions
about the proof so far
can go back to the example yes
definitely
so correct me if i run um
like if i'm looking at this example
where k is roughly log w
um similar to like
a tribe when i'm like doing like an aura
offense or
instead of an end of force
um
yeah i mean if you want to write this as
a cnf when it's reversed if it's an end
of ours right
right it's a dnf
right it's a very simple cnn it's like
it's
the same as tribes but as a cnn forum
yeah
we w yes and then when you convert it to
a
dnf it becomes a with wdnf with many
many terms
yes
so maybe also explain why you know this
doesn't
work because we know that for for the
tribe function it's uh
right somewhat like random restrictions
do not work uh with these mild
parameters yes
yes yes because i see there's one
question here asking about
can i briefly hint and how this helps
improving threshold results in random
graph 3. yes i have a slide on that in
few minutes so i'll get to that
this this example it gives you a
function which is a
uh case spread but but doesn't give a
contract
because it has disjoint sets yes yes it
says the journal
for example take all the elements in the
first column the second column in the
third column
so it does have this joint sets yes
but if i call the elements randomly it
will not have this monochromatic
um so maybe you need a
more algorithmic way to find this joint
somehow search
uh clever search to find yes yes so i
mean we have various ideas on how to
maybe try to modify but software none of
them will work so
that's what i would tell them about them
but yeah i mean if you try to say maybe
we do random coloring but we do
something else so you don't do it
randomly you do it somehow greedily or
you just yeah all i know is random
coloring and hoping for it to work
doesn't work
but maybe something else does well
whether here if you say just take a
random coloring and try to find like a
this monochromatic sunflower that this
would actually
exist but what you will not find here
are 3d
random like you have a random coloring
here then i will not find
three these join sets one being red one
being green one being blue
because for example with hyper ability
there is a role that's all red
so you cannot find the sets all green
that's maybe one one if you don't care
about the depends of on p
that's one way to say it
okay so let me continue
with and i'll tell you about a few
applications so one application that
at least i found surprising is this
interesting structure for intersecting
set systems
so there's an intersecting set system so
i have a set system f and some
universe n we say it's intersecting if
every pairs of sets in f intersect
that's an interesting set system and you
know there's a very famous
result in in combinatorics called the
score other theorem
that says well if we have an
intersecting ws system
its size cannot be super big so i mean
then
how how big could the w set system be in
the universe
of size n well and choose w right all
the subsidized w
but they prove that but if it's
intersecting it has to be somewhat
smaller size at the most
n minus one choose w minus one this is
tight why because
you can take all the sets that contain a
special element
let's take the first element in the
universe
all my sets must contain this one
element and then
on the other n minus one elements this
would be arbitrary sub subsets w minus
one
let's let's bounce this tight but you
think this example is
is sort of it's not very symmetric right
there's this one element
that is special it belongs to all the
sets
so here's a question could you hope to
find the most symmetric looking
intersecting set system where there is
no
one element or few elements that belong
to all or too many of the sets
and one quality of what we proved is
that this is not true
so there must be a specialty
where this number of sets in this
sets t is almost one over log into the t
and this is just a direct correlation
because if this doesn't happen
then our set is case spread for k being
logins it must contain
many disjoint sets in particular it
could be in the second so just a way of
reinterpreting
the same result but i want to make here
in a
comparison to what to this case well
it's not intersecting but almost
intersected so you know usually in
combinatorics
though when we have some extreme result
you can relax some
some constraints and say well this would
look roughly the same
and here's the case where this doesn't
happen so let me say the set system is
almost intersecting
if not maybe all the pairs but at least
99 of the pairs of sets intersect
and i'm claiming if this happens then
the behavior is very very different
but if i take for example the family of
all sets of n
of size something like root n some
constant
then if you choose this constantly large
enough say 10 then it's almost in the
second you take
two random sets of size root 10 n with a
very very high probability that will
intersect
but on the other hand the links decrease
much much faster see the base here
is log n and the base here is available
so there's a very very big a quantity of
difference
between intersecting set systems and
almost intersecting subsystems
which to me was surprising i mean the
fact that making this constraint hard
really changes qualitatively the
behavior of the threat system you must
now have some special sets
okay so this is one application the
other one was this question that aroused
on thresholds
so let me so this is what frankston and
khan nayanan and park proved
and what let me give you one example
let's say you're trying to prove
something like that
you take gnp so what is gnp it's a
random graph on n vertices
where every edge appears in probability
p
so there is this of classical that asks
well what value of p do i need
to guarantee that high probability my
graph has a
and the answer is up to constants logan
over n
and now
what is a new proof given this
conjecture
you say well take all matchings
house spread is a set of all matchings
in a in a graph and that's you can do a
simple calculation that's going to be
something linear in n
so what you do is you take this number
you inverse it
c over n you multiply by log n you'll
know
so it's a one over that times log n
and and the point is that this is true
now two always for any type of structure
trying to find
usually this thing i mean you need this
cond this the slogan over and usually
it's easy to prove that
p has to be at least that by some simple
calculations otherwise
high probability the expected number of
matching is going to be very small
and like lesson one and then this new
proof show that by multiplying this by
login
anyway that's it's this type of
dependency
and and getting this type of spread this
is a simple calculation
so you could do it for matching or
hamiltonian cycle so whatever structure
might all right coloring or whatever
you're addressing right
it's usually simple calculation now so
this is what they proved
and turns out to prove that the main
thing they needed
is to remove these law order terms in
our in our analysis
and if you want to see more than the
original paper yeah
any questions about that i know at least
one person had a question
on this application
so this seems to to show that this login
and another reason why this login is is
needed right now yes yes yes yes yes
exactly
that would be another reason why this
login is needed
that's yes like for example if you think
what do i want let's say this with a
very simple event i want
i don't want any node to be isolated
right so i want my graph to contain
some connected graph and saying well
what's the probability of that
well every now if you choose p to be one
over n
then every node is constant probably
they've been
you know disconnected from everything to
not have an edge
and or let's say let's see if something
is easier i want i want every node to
touch at least a single edge right even
a very simple event i want every node to
have at least
degree one so if i choose p to be one
over n
then with constant probability a node
has degree
at least one but if but to take a union
bond over all
and now they need these slogans and
loganovine but so this is where you
put this log in and this happens in many
other similar
scenarios for similar reasons
and now we can ask how [ __ ] push this
framework
oh there was a question in the chat see
okay somebody saying hi
um so
so again if you want to use this spread
condition
as is then this log w is tight so i mean
whether you're trying to find
satisfying conditions or we have another
example
that i haven't showed you let's show
that
your settings could be case spread but
it does not have
three digits like even if it even does
not have two digits it's in the second
set system
sorry application two seems to have more
to do with your lemma than with the
sunflower such yes this is true
the application too is not with the
sunflower lemma but the way we prove the
sunflower
this is true
um yes i mean there's another example i
haven't shown you but we can actually
build
a set system that is intersecting
but k is very close to log double it's
log over log log
so to that extent you can get
much better than log like maybe lower
volume but nothing better than that even
if you're just trying to find two
different sets
so in that sense so we'll start at w
although it's interesting whether it's
actually w or not but
there's one like ray of hope here which
is
there is a more defined notion of
randomness that might be useful
so let me call this k bounded
so what's the difference so
in a k bound that we're saying the set
system has skaters that at least catches
w
and every link is small so it seems to
be the same so what's the difference
in case spread the link size
is relative to the side of the whole set
system if it makes this decision bigger
i'm also allowing you to take the set
the links to be bigger as long as the
ratio is maintained
but k bounded i don't allow you you're
allowed to take the statistics
to be bigger but you're not allowed to
make the links bigger
okay that seems like a mild restriction
now we have examples of k-bonded
set systems which are not satisfied for
that we also need log w
but we don't have example of k bonded
with no 3-digion sets
so i want in the next slide i'll tell
you a bit more about it but to me that's
one possibility that by refining the
pseudo-randomness
property we might be able to get beyond
this
log w barrier and beyond what we can get
satisfying
so again here on the top of this
definition
f is k bounded if it has size at least k
to the w but every link
is bounded in some absolute value not
relative to f
and here the conjecture if f is k
bounded for some
constant k and 100 then it cannot
be an intersecting set system okay
another way of saying that
if i have an intersecting set system it
cannot be
k bounded for some large enough k
equivalent statement
and notice this is this will not
directly imply anything about sunflower
but if
not intersecting is the same as saying
not containing two disjoint sets
so not intersecting means containing two
disjoint sets
if i replace this with containing three
joint sets i would have a sunflower or
three or four or five
and i don't think there should be any
major difference if you can through this
for in the second set systems
they should be the same i don't see any
any major difference i think a very
interesting
open question is to prove what this for
this conjecture i mean either to find an
example
of an intersecting set system that is k
bond for k which is super constant
auto pull doesn't exist
um and again
we have an example like that if we
replace k bounded with
a k spread so in our example it's k
spread kb
like that log w but f is slightly more
than k to the double so somehow doesn't
quantify that
and i believe the example we have in the
paper
okay it's a bit of what future works i
mean one thing i'm interested in
trying to exploit is be good if people
write this as well i think well we have
these new techniques what else can we
apply them for so there were these
applications
to random graph theory that you know
very interesting to learn about
you can ask what about other ramsey
profits and combinatorics that are many
well we don't know the right bounds and
we hope that maybe
you know these techniques will help us
make progress and also these questions
coming from tcs
about structure of dnfs and if we go to
my ccc talk
they gave last week i speak in some more
detail about that
there are various questions that we are
interested in about structure of dnfs
that we don't understand and maybe these
techniques would be useful
and by the way we already had one
application of a similar type of ideas
but we now have like optimal bounds on
something called dnf compression
and but other questions that are
interested that we still don't know
like for example that are more about a
fourier structure of dns
another area what this seems to be
useful but we only have some preliminary
results so far is in
lifting theorems in communication
complexity that these techniques seem to
be
useful to get better bounds and of
course we should still prove the
sunflower conjecture
um okay so that's it thanks
thank you good time for questions
right i guess uh right so let's let's
take a few questions
all right chad oh thanks
i guess we weren't shy and we asked
questions along the top
very good but i know if people have some
open-ended questions or anything
really
so i know some versions of the
sunflowers were used in
circle complexity so do you think you
can improve
uh circuit complexity bounds using your
methods
it's a very good question so i know that
many of these techniques were used
when somebody was in circumplace in many
applications were in a
a fixed parameter tractability
i think for some of the applications
this doesn't prove anything because
r was more than was bigger than
constant and bigger than w in which case
the output of the w term was a dominant
one
in some applications yeah i mean i know
that ben rossmann
had some applications where they get
that the better low band for monotone
circuits
yeah because that was one area where
people use the sunflowers
and yeah i'm not sure so using the
robust sunflowers
we're able to improve the monotone
circuit lower bounds to
exponential and square root n so this is
a paper
in latin latin 2020.
there's another question in the q a yeah
but ben is the expert on the thing so he
should answer
any other applications that's right
complexity
so shut up there's another question in
the q a oh there's another question in
the q
and a okay why the exponential decrease
condition on all t
instead of t of bonded size related to w
um so if you think about the proof we
needed
to be of size w over two
so it's already pretty big sets to begin
with but really if you want to optimize
the parameters
then you need to choose t to be of size
very big and
it's a much much closer to w so in the
proof we had this was like you know one
minus epsilon times w
where epsilon was some slowly decreasing
function and instead of this new proofs
they don't do it explicitly but
implicitly these things happen there
so i think we do need this condition for
t's of size almost up to w
so why not ask all the way up to w it
doesn't really save you much
and in particular i think we can build
examples
that are spread up to some size
but do not justify this satisfying
condition
um so if you do this so we have some
examples where you do need that
at least up to size lena and w let's say
all right so
i want to thank shakha again this was
excellent i really enjoyed it
and uh our next meeting is on wednesday
in two days
uh we'll have uh i believe name and done
and we will send our reminder um
via email right and also let me thank
avishain prasad for organizing this
series i think it was really great i
mean i watched the previous two talks
and
it was really really nice really nice
talks and really nice
thank you for organizing it thank you
for talking thank you
thank you for really nice talk today
all right